another devastating 24 hours and this is
what's left of the coastal town of
mallacoota with cooler conditions on
Wednesday firefighters and residents
took a moment to count the costs a once
popular holiday destination now looks
like a war zone all of my positions have
been totally incinerated everything
there is just simply nothing military
ships an aircraft had been deployed to
provide humanitarian assistance bringing
in much-needed food and medical supplies
at least 18 people have been killed in
the fire so far and almost 1300 homes
destroyed a few residents stayed behind
determined to save their properties are
siding for dare but I decide anybody
don't stay just go the Meissner I just
go just get it okay just what you do is
put your life at risk there's now no
need to just go just get out and go when
you see that for and you just know
you're not meant to be there just go 240
kilometers along Australia's
southeastern coast is now a designated
evacuation zone people have been told to
leave as soon as possible as authorities
warn the worst is yet to come
there is every potential the conditions
on Saturday will be as bad or worse than
we saw yesterday the winds are expected
to be very strong back to 40-plus
degrees temperatures we've got a lot of
fire in the landscape that we will not
contain the fires now cover more than 5
million hectares an area bigger than
Denmark or the Netherlands the massive
clouds of smoke are now also visible
from New Zealand almost two thousand
kilometers away let's get the very
latest now let's go straight to Sydney
and a journalist Roger Maynard is
standing by for us Roger g'day to you
when's the Navy gonna start boarding the
evacuees at the beaches outside
mallacoota arrived a few hours ago
HMS Schutz is now position just offshore
at our Merrick kuta it's going to carry
much-needed supplies to the mainland
first food water that sort of thing and
the actual evacuation of the 4,000
people stranded in maracuja will begin
first thing in the morning but they
can't all go at once of course now how
long will this evacuation process take
we're talking about 4,000 people that we
know about but we're also hearing that
more and more people are arriving at the
beaches how long is this going to take
well this is there are an estimated
4,000 people in mallacoota at the moment
the ship can you take a thousand people
at the time and so once it leaves it's
got another 17 or 18 hour voyage along
the Victorian coast before it can
deposit people back on the mainland then
it has to make the return trip so if
you've got three or four thousand people
trying to get out it's gonna take you
know several days for the operation to
be completed now the good news is that
the families anyway with pets of dogs
and cats will also be allowed on this
naval vessel but it's gonna take some
time certainly before this operation is
completed ran ok we'd like to get an
idea of the scope of
happening in New South Wales right now
emergency orders have been placed on on
that state thousands of people are
evacuating how many people are we
talking about on the road right now and
and will supplies hold out for them gas
supplies for example well the estimate
is there about 50 55,000 people are
stranded in the air at the moment not
only holidaymakers and tourists but
people who live in the area - and
they're all being nice to get out as
quickly as possible our problem is that
fuel suppliers have been running very
very low over the past couple of days
some petrol stations have run out
altogether one - petrol tankers have
managed to get back into the main towns
in the past four or five hours so
suppliers have been replenished again
when it's still going to take a long
time for all these people to get out of
the main fire zone they're only in a
limited number of roads they can use
which are open at the moment but the
police are saying get out now while you
can don't wait until tomorrow because
tomorrow is gonna be dreadful okay this
is very much all about logistics right
now what's a very fast-moving story
Roger manor Forest thank you very much
for that